michel onfray bonsoir j'ai survécu à un
infarctus deux avc et un an des manuels
macro et vous êtes toujours là oui un an
de macron c'est le pire quand même c'est
vrai c'est pire qu'un infarctus et 2
alors michel vous racontez votre
deuxième avc dans un livre intitulé le
deuil de la mélancolie journal d'un avc
c'est un livre splendide et je dis pas
ça parce qu'il met dédié je dis ça parce
qu'il est aussi dédié à ma femme enfin
lorsque les gens me disent pourquoi est
ce que le livre de michel onfray était
dédié jeudi parce que ma pensée l'à
beaucoup inspiré
alors tout commence sur un quai de la
gare saint lazare mais la sncf n'est
pour rien en faire il est arrivé à
l'heure cette fois ci au bout du quai je
me suis sentie comme troué par une
lumière intérieure percée forêt
traversée perforé dans le cerveau oui
j'étais allé faire un tour sur les
traces d' art au mexique et j'avais vu
des clous d'utiliser les pré colombien
pour faire des sacrifices et en
obsidienne et quand j'avais vu ses clous
ça vous devez donner une drôle de
sensation dans le cerveau et j'ai une
impression vraiment qu'on montre est
inclus dans le cerveau avec un coup de
masse j'ai cru que j'aidais m'effondrer
coup d'obsidienne
la cinq médecins différents ne font pas
le bon diagnostic et le 2 février 2018
vous êtes sur le plateau d' audrey
crespo mara et en vous entendant dire du
bien des manuels macron elle s'inquiète
c'est pas exactement avec 2 s'est passé
mais un peu parce qu'effectivement j'ai
eu je suis rentré immédiatement dans la
foulée j'ai pris le train de retour je
veux aller aux urgences à caen et le mon
médecin me dit le médecin que j'ai vu
aux urgences pas dit ça n'est pas un avc
j'ai appelé mon toubib qui m'a dit ça
n'est pas un avc un ami qu'il l'était
mais il l'est plus c'était aux airelles
qui me dit ça n'est pas un avc j'ai fait
mon cours à l'université populaire le
lendemain y avait mille personnes j'ai
trouvé du coup tout de même j'avais des
papillons partout autour des yeux un
terrible mal de tête j'ai fait une
conférence en plus le jeudi et puis
j'étais sur le plateau de voitures
d'audrey en fait audrey vos interviews
ensuite elle nous envoie un sms dans le
taxi en visant michèle d'ouvriers quand
même aller voir un radiologue quoi pour
faire un irm elle m'appelle moi j'étais
en train de déjeuner et c'est vrai que
je réponds à personne sauf à ma femme
évidemment elle me dit qu'il faut
trouver un radiologue appel gombert
retrouver un radiologue pour pour michel
et vous y allez oui on m'a fait un texto
adorable en me disant je vous en conjure
détourner votre taxi est allé cet
endroit où on fera une irm et de fait
c'est là qu'on a vu qu'il y avait une
vraie patate et c'était une c'était un
avc voilà là vous êtes hospitalisé donc
à foch donc cinq médecins étaient passés
à côté le pire de tous dit vous si le
docteur
parce que lui vous avez assuré qu'il
n'est pas un avc mais ensuite il a nié
avoir faire un faux diagnostic en
maintenant fait qu'il savait que c'est
un avc n'est qu'il vous l'avez pas dit
pour vous épargner des émotions
oui c'est d'abord quelqu'un qui
maintient m'a demandé comment allait
manger du rin alors je me suis demandé
pourquoi si j'avais un premier avec ma
prostate je me vois bien qu'à des
relations entre entre ma prostate et mon
cerveau mais je vois pas là un élément
précis où ça aurait pu passer ce jour là
et il s'est trompé de will a fait une
erreur de diagnostic il m'a dit vous
avez un problème de vitré donc l'oeil
mais après un rendez vous chez un
ophtalmo à paris dans cet après midi
vous irez voir etc et quand je suis allé
chez le docteur lambert une heure plus
tard lui m'a dit non non pas du tout
c'est un avc alors les causes de cet avc
en fait c'est que les de nice mme sa
bouche les artères c'est ça
oui si on en remet mais il n'y a pas de
problèmes de tuyauteries et c'est ça le
problème j'ai fait un infarctus à 28 ans
vous l'avez rappelé il n'y a pas
d'explication à notre avis un premier
avc pas d'explication deuxième avc pas
d'explication né dans la médecine de
molière dans deux siècles on rira de
notre propre média fourier froid russe
je veux qu'on dira ah ben voilà il avait
juste pas un gène qui est un conte à
isoler et puis voilà alors aujourd'hui
on vous dit il faut pas ceci il faut pas
cela par exemple on vous dit est ce que
vous faites bien du sport ce que vous
faites du vélo est ce qu'on fait de la
natation vous buvez peut-être trop où je
suis mais trop vous êtes peut-être
stresser les enfants dans leurs berceaux
font des avc ils sont peu susceptibles
de mal manger à boire à son déclic ne
pas faire à sept vélos ainsi moins on
fait des avc en fait quand votre femme
est décédée vous le dites dans livrés
pensé partir avec elle est en fait vous
êtes retrouvé seul un fidèle à votre
promesse il fallait vivre quand même et
là vous n'êtes ni à manger à boire à
prendre trop de médicaments et à courir
dans tous les sens pour vous occuper
l'esprit un peu je bois depuis toujours
mais peut-être trouve jamais été ivres
mais j'étais dans des quantités un peu
d'ogre et j'ai pris 15 kilos à 50 et
donc ses 15 kg personne ne m'a dit ce
serait bien que tu les perds 10 comprime
un médecin un médecin ami qui aurait pu
me dire font un peu ça ne fera pas de
mal prenait beaucoup de médicaments
c'est à dire antibiotiques cortisone
antihistaminiques sur plein de choses
oui fait des allergies ouais c'est ça
acariens donc le début de saison a
commencé antibiotiques cortisone etc et
on accumule une espèce de pollution
pharmaceutique et médicamenteuses et on
dira aussi probablement un jour combien
les médicaments tu bois là il faut le
dire aux gens faut pas trop en prendre
moi non voilà en fait vous étiez en
train de vous suicider à petit feu d'une
certaine façon oui je crois que
j'essayais d'être fidèle à ma parole
sans envoyer un coup de fusil dans la
tête je crois que j'étais en train de me
sui 6 et 10 ans mans et que ce suicide
ou bien nous dire où il va falloir tout
soit clair est-ce que c'est un vrai
suicide ou voilà voilà et si c'est pas
un vrai suicide alors on continue à
vivre et si on continue alors il faut
faire d'où le titre le deuil de la
mélancolique voilà alors les
conséquences de tout ça c'est
effectivement vous avez changé de mode
de vie donc j'ai perdu 10 15 kg c'est
cependant bien le plus dur c'est quoi
perdre 10 kilos ou perdre ses illusions
c'est perdre ses amis ouais parce que
effectivement il ya des gens qui ne font
plus signe des gens qui n'appelle pas il
ya des gens qui n'en a pas de textos et
des gens qui ont l'impression que les
avc sont contagieux et on ne se fait
piéger charognards aussi qui vous
appelle à l'hôpital pendant la dernière
interview de michel onfray oui olivier
les éditeurs savoir si vraiment je vais
encore pouvoir signer des contrats alors
au sujet de votre cerveau vous dites mon
cerveau s'avère être mon meilleur ami et
mon meilleur ennemi c'est vrai oui parce
que je suis sorti de mon milieu faisions
nos milieux modestes milliers de mes
parents grâce aux livres grâce à
l'écriture de réseau à mon travail
cérébral ah oui et puis on se dit bon
quand même là de deux avc pour un seul
personnage ça fait quand même beaucoup
alors vous avez quand même perdu un
quart de votre champ visuel
qui fait que là vous voyez pas du tout
laurent baffie qui vous fait un doigt
d'honneur sur le côté là
laurent maurice du progrès qu'il soit là
aussi de bord supérieur gauche
la mort rôde autour de vous depuis votre
enfance
vous êtes tenté par l' angoisse la mort
je n'en ai pas peur mais je suis est
elle est présente depuis depuis toujours
un jeu raconte un peu que j'ai eu un
vieux papa quand j'ai su dès mon père
avait 38 ans et que très vite j'ai eu
peur qu'il parte et il partit à 88 ans
et pendant tout ce temps là j'ai
toujours eu peur que quelques jours on
arrive à un moment donné où on se calme
un peu avec ça mais c'est un peu l'avers
et le revers de la médaille le recto et
le verso de la même feuille c'est à dire
que les de nice n'est pas possible sans
un sentiment aigu de la mort il faut
savoir que la vie est courte brève que
chaque seconde perdue est définitivement
perdu pour la récupérera pas à la
punition elle est ici et maintenant qui
a pas de paradis ya pas de récompense ya
rien au delà mais qu' il veut il faut
pas rater sa vie on en a qu'une fois
l'avis ne repasse pas les plats
aujourd'hui le malheur le deuil est
traitée comme une maladie oui d'abord
j'ai toujours dit depuis la mort de mon
père d'abord puis celle de marie claude
après qu' on ne fait pas son deuil mecs
le deuil qui nous fait et donc on n'y
pas un jour oui voilà il ya une espèce
de feuille de route du genre dans les 15
jours et se passe et ce à trois semaines
après un mois après et vous allez passer
parce si vous allez passer par cela ça
veut rien dire on perd des gens qu'on
aime qu'on aime pas on perd des gens
qu'on déteste on perd des gens proches
on perd des gens âgés on s'est préparés
à la mort de certains certains partent
d'un seul coup d'autres ont 15 ans de
maladie cette année de chimiothérapie
pour marie-claude non-stop donc
évidemment il n'y a pas une feuille de
route du deuil mais c'est le deuil qui
nous fait parce qu'effectivement il faut
vivre avec ceux qui sont partis et il
faut pas succomber il faut pas il faut a
succombé à la mort des gens qui sont
partis l'athée que je suis se dit la
meilleure façon d'être fidèle aux gens
qui sont morts c'est de vivre sous leur
regard quand on les a aimés et est en ce
sens que la mort est acceptable
bel avenir alors michel est ce que vous
pensez que vous seriez plus heureux si
vous croyez en dieu je pense aux fins
dans l'idée que je me fais de la
croyance en dieu il ya quand même cette
idée forte que la mort n'est pas la mort
et la mort c'est le début d'une autre
vie dans cette autre vie on va retrouver
les gens qui sont morts et qui nous ont
quittés que la vie d'après finalement
elle est en relation avec la vie d'avant
et si on a tué des gens c'est bien qu'on
porte si on s'est bien comportée on a
mérité son paradis si on croit vraiment
des fariboles pareil on doit se dire
mais vive la mort écoutez je crois que
le plus simple c'est d'en parler avec
dieu
michel
c'est dieu qui te parles tu m'entends
dis moi tu vois encore fait faux bond
non mais c'est toi qui n'a pas fait le
boulot jusqu'au bout puisque vous
tutoyez dieu en battant il me tutoie
donc
je vous rappelle que depuis vatican ii
mais tu te crois que oui c'est pas peu
fière d'eux on lui parle en français
michel tu n'as pas envie de voir ce que
la vie après la mort réserve
je serais assez tenté par l'hypothèse de
découvrir autre chose mais ce serait
plutôt de l'astrophysique nom qui
m'intéresserait pas sur ce terrain là
l'ailé les monde inversé cette idée que
le temps peut être commandé un raging et
c'est à dire qu'on veut on retourne ça
comme le doigt d'un gant un vrai presque
revivre al'inverse qu'on aurait vécu si
dieu était vraiment un astrophysicien ça
m'intéresserait d'avoir une conversation
avec dieu
et dieu j'ai pas la barbe mais quand
même je vais j'essaie de paires d'yeux
quoi michel qu'est ce qui te donne tant
envie de rester sur terre à part le
fromage le bon vin
ah ça c'est une bonne question
je crois que la vie en tant que tel est
une et une chose fabuleuse il ya en moi
une force qui me veut ce qu'une personne
appelée l'élan vital et cette force qui
me veut et elle est pour l'instant plus
forte qu'une force qu'ils ne voudraient
plus via les femmes si ça donne envie de
rester sur terre non
on change d'époque canton quand on
change de décennies je vais avoir 60 ans
le 1er janvier prochain le rapport aux
femmes n'est plus du tout le même donc
ça paraît évident que le les collections
qu'on peut faire quand on a 30 ans on ne
les fait plus et on est plutôt non plus
dans une logique de cherchent quelque
juste quantité dans une logique de
qualité mais dès qu'on avait la quantité
épicurienne quand on a 30 ans on a la
qualité stoïcienne quand on a 75 ans on
perd
ça il faut dire que j'ai vécu 37 ans
avec marie claude et qu'il y avait dans
ma vie dorothée depuis 25 ans que marie
claude connaissait l'existence de
dorothée que dorothée connaissait
l'existence de de marie-claude heurté à
d'ailleurs été formidable sur la fin de
marie claude m'a aidé pour les
bouteilles d'oxygène de marie-claude et
hétéros sont des choses qu'on raconte
pas vous
vous me amené je le dis pour l'allemagne
un job et jeux libres la première fois
je suis content que ce soit chez vous et
il se fait que oui dorothée à un grand
garçon deux grandes filles victoire et
avec michaël qui est un adorable garçon
ils ont fait tous les deux un petit
augustin qui n'est pas simple mais qui
est adorable donc moi qui n'ai pas été
père je me retrouve grand-père
félicitait
michel onfray
je voudrais te poser une question qui me
taraude l'esprit
pourquoi top 100 du temps à vouloir
prouver que je n'existe pas
je ne prouve pas l'inexistence de dieu
je suis dans une logique
judéo-chrétienne j'en suis je suis un
judéo-chrétien 20 siècle derrière nous
de quinze siècles on dire à jésus pour
moi est une fiction c'est pas un
personnage historique et ce qui
m'intéresse comme philosophe c'est de
voir comment tout ça ce qui construit et
que dieu soit le dieu monothéiste non ce
ne sera pas avec une barbe ou sans barbe
qu'il est d'aider des sentiments humains
qui est puis se venger qui puisse
récompenser qu'ils puissent tout voir
tout savoir ça pour moi c'est une
fiction à l'évidence mais j'ai pas envie
forcément de nommer dieu ce que
l'astrophysique nous enseigne s'il ya
effectivement d'autres vies ailleurs si
notre vie continue sous d'autres formes
moi j'attends que là physiquement fasse
la démonstration et si on veut appeler
ça dieu j'ai rien contre dieu ce qui me
gêne dans le dieu ce sont les gens qui
s'en réclament pour imposer leur mode de
vie les autres
mais ce qui me gêne dans dieu ce sont
les religions disons michel
si j'existe est vraiment que
souhaiterait tu m'as d'hyères disparaît
comme
il ya un truc là une chose à laquelle je
pense là la question colombo
[Musique]
dites-moi michel onfray ya un truc qui
me chagrine nous inquiète beaucoup
emmanuel macron on en bave à tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs dans la battle mais
chaque fois vous dites que emmanuel
macron est en roi et c'est même pas du
tout vous avez vu de crown non quand on
voit de quoi on comprend que macro n'est
pas un droit c'est au plus à un
dictateur libéral mais c'est parfois pas
très cool pour les rois de dire que
macro est un roi parce que les rois sont
beaucoup plus respectueux des
institutions qu emmanuel macron je vous
garantis que vous avez raison c'est
vraiment c'est vrai je suis dans un
esprit polémique dont s'est noyé dans ce
genre de tête donc pour beaucoup le roi
c'est le pouvoir autocratique et moderne
chez x et une pouvoir d'un individu qui
décide s'il y en a quatre cebu 14 sél et
les rois d'aujourd'hui il se comporte
beaucoup mieux qu'elle m'a complètement
raison mais même louis saez - mais oui
c'est le ferrand pour le oui bien sûr
bien sûr et même pour louis xiv d'une
certaine manière va pas comparer ce qui
est comparable
weiss et l'anachronisme de comparer
absolument mais c'est une façon de
parler quand on a vraiment l'impression
que les révolutionnaires sont tous des
gentils coin les rois sont tous des
méchants je jouais un peu sur ça mais
historiquement c'est vous qui avez
raison merci alors il ya eu pas mal
d'histoires la benne un fait incroyable
histoire des bennes à la perquisition
chez benalla tient y va avec les flics
chez lui il n'a pas la clé on demande un
bélier au commissariat le commissariat
de laon n'a pas de bélier tout le monde
à se coucher y a pas un seul flic qui
restent devant la porte de bena là et le
lendemain matin quand on y retourne on
s'aperçoit que le fameux coffre qui doit
contenir on ne sait quoi a disparu et le
parquet refuse de poursuivre donc la
sphère est enterré oui donc on est chez
pasqua on est barbouzeries là tout est
dit exactement mais il ya plein
d'histoires comme ça depuis le début et
avec pas mal de gens il ya un ace alcool
compagnies interdites réhabilite voilà
une dame qui a utilisé des taxis des
taxis pour ses enfants 40000 euros de
frais de taxi à l'époque où elle
travaillait à li na pour ses enfants et
cette dame qui a été condamné à vue de
la promotion promotion macron promotion
soutenue par madame nissen qui elle est
dans l'illégalité aussi avec
l'augmentation de 2 sur la surface des
cdo et sa maison mais aussi la
nomination de philippe besson là il
vient d'être nommé donc consul consul à
los angeles
avec là encore une décision personnelle
c'est à dire qu'il l'a il ya eu un
décret qui a été signé par macrophages
un choisi est décidée pour qu'on puisse
choisir quelqu'un qui sortent et voilà
où du raout ya un décret du quai d'orsay
d'un creusement le quai d'orsay nomme
des gens à ce poste là ça suppose comme
des compétences quand on est consul de
france là-bas en joue un rôle
extrêmement important est le fait qu on
écrit des romans ça ne suffit pas donc
effectivement on est dans une dictature
libérale pour le coup alors elle c'est
au nom du libéralisme de l'argent et du
marché et de fait on peut se dire mais
les gens qui ont cru que macro
changerait quelque chose
ne se sont regroupés et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu